this morning nearly one month after
impeaching President Trump House leaders
are now ready to send two articles of
impeachment to the Senate the president
prepared for his upcoming trial with a
full-throated attack at a campaign rally
in Milwaukee last night Democrats in
Congress are wasting America's time with
demented hoaxes and crazy witch hunts
that have been going on by the way from
the day I came down the escalator with
our future first lady Nancy Cordes is
inside the US Capitol with more on this
part of the story Nancy how do we expect
this all to play out today
well Speaker Pelosi Gayle is going to
finally name her impeachment managers in
a couple of hours and then late this
afternoon those managers will make the
ceremonial walk with the articles of
impeachment through the Capitol down
this very hallway they are going to be
marching the articles from the House
chamber through the statuary hall
through the rotunda along the second
floor of the Capitol passed the old
Senate chamber through the Ohio clock
corridor and then eventually to the
Senate chamber and then the ball is in
the hands of Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell he has said that the
trial is going to start next week and
new evidence indicates the lengths that
some of the president's allies were
apparently willing to go to to dig up
dirt on the Biden's and those lengths
may have included tracking a US
ambassador the impeachment hoax it's a
total hoax hours before President Trump
railed against impeachment at a campaign
rally in Wisconsin the House
Intelligence Committee released new
evidence from Lev Parnas an indicted
businessman who helped the president's
personal attorney Rudy Giuliani pressure
Ukraine to investigate the Biden's in
one text exchange between Parnassus and
ukraine's top prosecutor at the time
yuriy lutsenko
appeared to agree to help with the Biden
investigation if the US ambassador to
Ukraine was removed this has been a very
painful period former ambassador Murray
Ivanovich testified last year that she
was ousted after being smeared by the
president and his
allies including Parnas text messages
suggest Parnassus and his associates
were tracking her movements in one text
Robert Hyde a Trump donor tells
Parnassus they know she's a political
puppet they will let me know when she's
on the move in a statement
Jovanovic his lawyer called for an
investigation writing the notion that
American citizens and others were
monitoring ambassador ivanovich's
movements for unknown purposes is
disturbing Democrats do acknowledge that
Parnassus self has some credibility
problems you think he may not be a
reliable witness somebody who's been
indicted for multiple felonies there are
questions of credibility there that have
to be processed through Democrats and
some key Republicans do want to hear
from other witnesses at the Senate trial
including former national security
advisor john bolton who has said he
would testify if you want the truth you
have to have witnesses you have to have
documents Senate Leader Mitch McConnell
is apparently considering some pretty
unprecedented restrictions on media
coverage of this upcoming Senate trial
restrictions that would include cutting
off reporters access to senators and
allowing just one video camera and no
photographs or audio recordings of the
trial while it is taking place the
Standing Committee of Correspondence
which is a group of reporters who cover
Capitol Hill sent a letter to senators
saying that the restrictions quote keep
reporters from fulfilling their
constitutional obligation to inform the
public about what elected officials are
doing on their behalf so this is a
debate that's going to be raging over
the next few days Joanie and we'll be
following it Nancy thank you very much
you